i actually tried to film this yesterday
but uh
it got dark and then kona stole the show
the link in the description box down
below so that you can check out all
their stuff oh hi kona
hey hi there you want to steal the show
huh
but now he's asleep in the back like a
cute little duck so we're doing this
again
hey everyone how's it going welcome back
to my channel and i hope you are well
so today's video is like a long overdue
video if you want to see a video about
how i bullet journal then leave a
comment down below
maybe i'll make it if y'all are
interested yeah
so i'm so sorry this video is so late
but i hope that this topic
still interests you and that you're
still interested in learning about it
and if not well i've got some great cool
stationery to talk about and i hope that
you'll stay and nerd out with me
because i love stationery and as much as
i'm like an ios developer
and a lot of apps and websites have kind
of replaced and displaced paper and pen
stuff
at the end of the day like that's my
favorite medium and there's something
that's really nice and organic and
natural feeling about
using pen and paper which you just can't
replace you know
but yeah we'll talk more about that in a
bit so today i'm going to show you my
stationery haul as well as my bullet
journal spread that i've been using for
like the last six months
we're going to talk about the stationary
hall first but i will also say that
this is the bullet journal spread that i
have it's actually a four page spread so
i will go over exactly how i made it and
how i use it
first let's talk about all the things
that i got because man am i excited
so all the things in this hall have
actually been gifted to me
by top drawer who is like one of my
favorite
favorite favorite stores they had a
bunch of stores in the bay area when i
lived there they also have stores all
over the u.s
but they're owned by a japanese
stationery company called itoya
and itoya is wonderful they have a
six-story
ish stationery store in ginza and it's
just
it's disneyland for stationery nerds and
so top drawer is a store
in the us they also have an online store
and so they've graciously gifted me all
these things that i've actually been
wanting
for a long long time all the products
are going to be listed in the
description box down below
they're all actually going to be
affiliate links because i'm an affiliate
of top card now which i'm so excited
like literally
this is a brand that i really wanted to
work with and when they reached out to
me i was like yeah let's do it
so i guess let's just get started so
we're first going to talk about
notebooks because they sent me four
and i love each of them dearly and the
first one i feel like we just gotta talk
about it like we have to just talk about
this midori notebook
this is the midori notebook with a5
gridded paper
these midori notebooks have quite a
reputation because a lot of people say
that this is their favorite notebook in
the whole world
so all the midori notebooks come wrapped
in this like parchment paper
which just gives us this really nice
like tactile
like asmr can you hear it
can you hear it you can take it off but
i just like how it feels with it on so i
keep it on
the notebook is a lay flat design which
is i feel like that's the kind of
binding you need to go with so
you flip to any part in the notebook and
it'll lay flat thanks to just how it's
binded
at the end right here they have a
variety of different kinds of paper that
you can choose from but i got the
gridded one because i feel like that's
the most like
multi-use like you can kind of just like
draw outside the lines and do whatever
you want
but if you really want some structure
you also got the grid to help you do so
it also comes with this bookmark that's
bound to so if you need a flip to the
page that you're on
then it's easy to do so with this and
then the pages they're just they're not
too thin actually it's got a good amount
of weight to them and they're super
duper
smooth and so ah midori notebook i also
just like
i love the smell of paper the experience
of notebooks is something very special
because not only does it like
smell super good it sounds really nice
and just being able to interact with
something
physical actually really helps me stay
grounded
so yeah that's notebook number one the
midori notebook notebook number two is
this one this one is actually by the
etoya company this is the
b6 five millimeter grid it has 80 sheets
it's actually pretty similar to the
midori notebook it's actually a little
bit
smaller but it's got a lot of pages
and the pages itself are gridded and
it's got that similar lay-flat design
like the midori one
the design of it is so nice i don't know
if you could also see the lines
on the front here so you can put your
own title as well as this little like
sticker here that i'm gonna keep the
grid itself
it's kind of got it's a little bit of a
darker color and so it's easy to see and
it goes
all the way to the edges of the paper
this one also comes in many sizes and
it's very flexible as well
the paper itself maybe has a little bit
less weight than the midori notebook but
the pages are
super duper smooth like they're really
really smooth
so that's this notebook the next one is
kind of a fun one this is the aji
notebook
so there's many notebooks in kind of the
fish series of notebooks
this was actually created by one of the
executives i think he was the ceo of
etoya
he really likes fishing and so he made
like a fish notebook
and it's just so cute the design is
super adorable
there's actually also one fish on here
that looks different from all the rest
and it's a pretty thin notebook there's
not that many pages on it
but it's also got that same kind of grid
and then on the inside there's like a
little recipe this one's for ajinohiraki
because
the this is this is a mackerel mackerel
notebook
oh this could honestly be like a good
food journal log
that's a really good idea i think i
might actually do that it really fits
too with this kind of like
horse mackerel theme so that's the macro
notebook the next one
is this big one this is the life noble
note
ruled notebook with 100 sheets and the
size is a4
so when i need space to think oftentimes
i will use a legal pad
i don't do well in thinking on like a
word processing platform because i feel
like just the rules of how you're
supposed to write in it and that it has
to be line by line and stuff
is really constraining and i like to
just kind of like write notes everywhere
and just
spill it out for my brain as they come
out so legal pads have always been kind
of a staple
in my toolbox and because this one is so
big this is effectively going to be
my new legal pad replacement and it's so
much prettier
there's so many pieces of paper on it
too in this one the paper itself is
lined the lines are nice and wide it's
actually this kind of like
cream color the pages also have a kind
of like nice
weight to them too it's also lay flat as
well
just like all the other notebooks which
i feel like is a must these days
but yeah it's really nice it's bigger
than my head it's a nice big notebook to
just think on
so yeah those are all of the notebooks
they are gorgeous and each of them
i'm going to find a really good purpose
for them this one i think is actually
going to be
my new main bullet journal so i'm
excited to get
started next we're going to talk about
pens there's two products one
is the stabilo pen so i think i was
actually recommended this on instagram
after i found a pen that was similar
but i wanted like more colors and i
wanted more of them and a lot of y'all
recommended this stabilo pen
top drawer sent me this pack there's 25
colors it's the point
88 fine liner in 0.4 millimeters point i
actually have the exact same set of this
and the colors i love they're super
duper vibrant
also because the point is really small
it's really good for writing it's really
good for drawing technical things
as well as just like spicing up your
notes and drawing
it's a really nice design the ink of
mine haven't run out
yet at all it's just a really nice way
to like
level up your pen game really quickly
the next pen is the koiko sport
this pen is so cute it's pretty small it
twists off
it's like a screw off and then you can
put this at the end right here so i've
been told that it's really good for
travel because for fountain pens the ink
can
leak out of your backpack or your purse
or whatever and so
the fact that this twists on make sure
that it won't just fall out and leak
everywhere it's a really compact size
this comes in many colors
i actually have another koako pen this
is the koiko perky oh so i think of this
one is kind of my entry into fountain
pens
this one i think like i use this daily
it's like my
favorite thing now it comes with a
cartridge of ink so i have the blue in
here right now but
i also was sent the koeco cartridges so
you can refill the ink at any time and
you can use this basically for forever i
think i might get more of these actually
the last thing in this haul is this
pencil case now colo is one of the
brands underneath each other so it's
exclusive to top drawer
but it's a nice gray canvas
pencil case and i've been wanting
something like this for a long time
it fits quite a lot i'm pretty sure that
i could fit all of my stabilo pens in
here
and then this leather strap it's a
really nice touch
to all of this this comes in many colors
and also many sizes you can actually use
them as like packing cubes because
they've got square ones and bigger ones
so yeah those are all the things in my
haul like i mentioned all of the
products are going to be linked in the
description box down below they're all
affiliate links so i will make a tiny
commission from your purchase
at no extra cost to you yeah i hope you
like these i
love buying so much stationery if i
could fill
this room with stationery i would and i
probably will
you should also check out the rest of
top drawers products they have an
incredible selection of things
i've bought a raincoat from them
sunglasses
my bento box i've bought a lot of
different things and they're all
super good quality and they're really
well designed
it's actually really dangerous because
when i used to like walk into a top
drawer store in the bay i'd be like i
want
everything in this store but their
online store has all the same stuff they
ship everywhere and so
definitely go check them out all right
so now let's talk about my bullet
journal
[Music]
so i've been bullet journaling for about
three or four years
and for those of you unfamiliar with
bullet journaling bullet journaling is
basically a system that you use
to do life basically i think honestly
everyone's got a different spread
some people use it just to journal other
people use it for task management
project management habit tracking
intention setting reflections it's
really just like whatever you want it to
be
which is kind of the beauty of it anyone
can create any sort of system that they
like that fits their needs
and that's because you're starting with
basically like a blank notebook and so
you create lines and quadrants and
systems for yourself
for however you want to do your life i
really enjoyed it because it's a really
good
easy scrappy quick way to be able to
do all the things that i want to without
necessarily like
needing to build an entire productivity
task management app for myself
and i change it frequently because at
some points in my life i want a journal
and some points i don't
and right now it's kind of like a mix of
task management plus
journaling plus habit tracking plus
intention settings so it's got a little
bit of everything
so without further ado let's dive in so
the bullet journal layout i use is
actually a four page setup and so i'm
actually going to
cut this part of this middle page right
here
so that i can see through to both sides
so i've just cut this part out it
doesn't need to be perfect
also with these lay flat journals i
actually don't want to cut it all the
way to here because there's a page on
the other side from the binding
so this is what i'm going to do for now
so this is kind of just
scrap paper that i can leave aside next
what i'm going to do is just make these
edges look a little bit prettier with
some washi tape and i guess meanwhile
while i do that i can talk about how i
started bullet journaling so i was
introduced to bullet journaling mostly
through my friend
charlie marie she's also a youtuber and
she makes a lot of kind of design
content and so i found out about bullet
journaling from her
and then her friend matt ragland uh who
she
worked with at convertkit also was kind
of like a fan of bullet journals and so
that's just like kind of how i started
i've been bullet journaling on and off
and it's on and off because some weeks i
just don't want a bullet journal
i think the thing that people get caught
on a lot is that bullet journals need to
be pretty
and that's true especially because
there's so many
pretty bullet journaling spreads out
there and mine definitely takes a little
bit of time but i've actually found a
lot of like
zen in doing these bullet journals but i
also don't beat myself up about it if i
don't
do one one week either so now i've cut
out that part it's like a little window
and then i also put washi tape on this
so that it's a little bit
cleaner and so now let's just start with
the spread so i have these colors picked
out because it's kind of like halloween
vibes up in here
but i don't really know if they're gonna
go out and so i actually use this piece
of paper
to test to see what color combinations i
like
and then see if it actually is one
that i enjoy
[Music]
so these are the first two pages of my
usual bullet journal spread
here i have four quadrants and these are
kind of just like
headlines for the week so this one i
just have a
calendar to show me what week it is and
also just a little calendar that i can
reference throughout the week
here i have like a little like konichiwa
like this week
theme place this is almost like if i
were to give myself
fortune cookies what would they say for
this week and what are some of the
reminders and themes that i have to make
sure so that
throughout the week as i'm filling this
out i can kind of check in to make sure
that i'm doing these things
next i have the schedule these are just
important things that i just want to
have in my mind
i also have a calendar that i use with
email
but here i can kind of see just here the
deadlines that i'm working with or here
are the important dates that are
otherwise hard to show in a calendar
here i have some ongoing projects
usually i have more than one going on
and so just being able to keep track of
the fact that i have many going on and
also maybe i'll write like a little
status update of here's what i'm doing
this week it's almost kind of like
sprint planning if you will of
here are the things that i'm working on
this week and then this breaks down
into tasks so this is the way that i've
been writing all of my tasks
i have a rolling task list style here
because i used to do something where i
would put
tasks per day but i found that that was
entirely too rigid for my workflow
because if i missed some of the tasks on
monday then they rolled over to tuesday
and by the end of the week i just had
all these rolled over tasks this way i
can see
exactly what are the things that i need
to do this week so that within the week
i can give myself a little bit of google
room
and do some of them or do none of them
it's just completely up to me and how
i'm feeling that week so here i have
some of the tasks that a lot of them are
kind of related to this ongoing project
but
i also have other things like calling
electrician cashing checks this is
really just like a
dump of all of my to-do lists they're
all from different parts of my life and
just having them all here
make sure that they all get done and
nested these tasks are the days of the
week and so what i do is
if there's a task that i need to do on a
certain day then i'll make kind of
squares like this to make sure that hey
these are the target dates for me doing
this task when i finish a task though
usually what i'll do is i'll just look
at the day that i did them
so today is monday and then i will kind
of just cross it off like this if i
was able to finish all this in one day
if i started it but i haven't finished
then what i'll do
is i'll do a slash like this maybe i'll
work on it on tuesday
and then i actually finish it on
wednesday in which case then it can be
done like that
and so when tasks are done i usually put
like an x right here just to make sure
that when i look
through everything i know that this one
is done i definitely have tasks that
roll over to the next week in which case
i use this column and that's just
for me to indicate hey i wasn't able to
do this this week and so i put one right
there to make sure that it can go over
to the next week and i can just look
through this list and easily see
what needs to roll over sometimes also
tasks become
not tasks in that i need to like not do
them anymore
or i don't have to do them anymore so in
that case i'll just kind of put a slash
like this
so this is all a very basic way to be
able to track all of my tasks
and throughout the week i'll just keep
adding to this i may or may not use
everything here but i do have space to
roll over
in case i want to so that's my first
page next we're gonna go on to
the third and fourth page so i'm gonna
write that out now all right so here's
my third
and fourth page spread so i've always
really wanted to be someone who can keep
a journal and remember all the days that
i've lived
but it's really hard to fill like an
entire page or even half a page
and so this is just one way that i found
it to be really easy to
be able to write a little bit of
something just so that i can remember
what i did each day
and so i have from sunday through
saturday it's not like a whole lot of
space but
it's just enough that i can talk about
what i did how i felt
and then i can look back on things and
see what i was up to
and i don't write every single day
sometimes i'll wait till like thursday
and then backfill some of those days but
it's really nice to just like sit down
and write down all the things that i did
and so i have from sunday through
saturday here
up here i've got like a little habit
tracker and there's not a lot of habits
that i'm trying to track
just because sometimes it can get
overwhelming but these are the ones that
i know that if i do them i'll feel much
better
so right now i have sleep more than
eight hours a night wake up by 7 30
exercise drink lots of water and
meditate
and so if i was able to do that the
previous night then i'll put a little
dot here
and then over the week i'll add all
these dots and it's really satisfying to
see when i'm able to complete a whole
row for a habit
and lastly for these two cells these are
parts that i fill out at the very end of
the week here i've got like a little
gratitude section
i feel like practicing gratitude is
really grounding
and i always want to make sure that i'm
grateful for something every week
and so again it's not a huge space but
just writing something so that i'm
always thinking about
how i'm thankful is another way to keep
me grounded and also
helps me to stay in touch with how i'm
feeling
and then in the reflection section i
talk about how my week went how i want
things to change from next week
and also just anything else that i
didn't get to write in these
like literally this is kind of just like
a form of sprint planning where this is
like the retrospective meeting that i
have with myself
because it's really nice just to have a
place to like introspect and reflect
and think about the week before and by
me writing it down every week in this
reflection section
make sure that i don't forget about the
lessons that i learned
so that's it that's kind of how i set up
my bullet journal i like having this
little window because then i
can be kind of on either page and be
able to see some of the reminders and
also dates as well as the habits that
i've set for myself the beauty of the
bullet journal though is that you can
set it up however way you want
and it can definitely evolve over time
too and so there are some weeks where
all i do is just write a task list and
that's it
but that's okay because that's what i
need for that week and that's my bullet
journal spread for the week but when i
can do it
this is one that has been working really
well for me it helps me to project
manage stay on top of things
stay grounded remember things and then
also
remember to stay healthy alright
everybody thanks so much for watching i
really hope you enjoyed seeing my bullet
journal set up as well as my stationery
haul
cod has been back there napping all the
time because maybe stationary calms him
and grounds him like it does for me
or it's just because the afternoon is
like the sleepiest time of
day for him let me know what you enjoyed
about this video and if you have any
ideas for future videos in the comments
down below
make sure to hit the subscribe button to
get more videos that i make and
that get published out into the world
for you all that i hope that you like
and watch
thanks again to topjoy for sending me a
bunch of stuff and make sure to check
them out
alright everyone take care and i'll see
you next time
bye